holy [ __ ] there's an actual trailer
i got my back cape let's do this let's
do this let's do it
no more lies oh
[Music]
i'm your secret friend
let's play a game just me and me
yes
um
[Music]
oh
he's just got his voice
this is like a like a like a fan film of
the life
oh my god
2031. that's right
oh
this is a new batman trailer this would
be batman
that oh looks
incredible it's incredible
it's incredible that looks incredible
oh my god holy crap
holy moly baby
tasers batman i really thought
all we were going to get today is like a
little bit of footage
i didn't think we'd get an actual
trailer and
wow does that deliver so much
to talk about there's so much here i
need a second to process my thoughts
second complete okay all right let's go
first thing fight the fight mode right
what was the one thing i was like really
saying i wanted
was like that demonstration of what ben
affleck did with
the the fight in the warehouse for this
one as much as i want a noir film i
really want that and
boy does it look like they're giving us
that i really wanted like
some great batman martial arts
fighting scenes and just that little
tease
and then even that one shower he's
grappling up and the camera just mounted
on him like an actual stunt performer
holy crap that was insane
now think of how much better that fight
could have been if robert pattinson
decided to work out
i think he's fine i think he did
actually pick up a waiter too looking at
this
and he said he said he said it
i am vengeance and and i was like wait
has has batman said that any of the live
actions yet
because that's one of his lines that's
one of his quotes
if he confirms that he's the knight
we'll have the whole thing
but yeah and plus we get a glimpse at
his bad voice and his bad voice sounds
great
it just sounds like a voice yeah it's
not some modulated
thing
it sounds like a really just rageful
dude
i feel like these guys on the streets
these gangster thugs they
i i get it i don't exactly know what
they're inspired by but i get a hint of
a bit of like joker followers meets
some of like the mutants from the frank
miller dark knight returns
[Laughter]
so too many thoughts sound design is
great materials said that this is like
batman uh like
this fighting for his soul in some way
and uh i reread the long halloween
i've forgotten a how great of a comic
that is and forgotten what it's about
and
matt reeves said or someone said that
this is a
a lot of it is inspired from it like the
dark knight definitely is but i'm seeing
even more inspiration from the long
halloween here
the relationship between him and gordon
um
him working with catwoman in this one
like this looks
still as early year selena kyle i wasn't
sure what time and place in their
storyline this would take place in
if she's already been catwoman for a
while um it seems pretty apparent that
they
don't seem like they know each other
yeah
uh they still seem like they're getting
accustomed to one another but they're
gonna
probably end up having to work together
and with the long halloween
uh focusing a lot on the killer holiday
this mystery killer they can't figure
out who's doing these
crimes who's doing these murders him
having to work with gordon
it pushing you know the the people in
the police department who are good
and batman into a really dark
place pushing them over the edge having
to deal with these these
criminals like what is the line of
justice having that debate
it's all here it's all present in this
trip in this one trailer alone
that whole mood and tone and badenson
looks
awesome this was a
nice surprise i'm so satisfied with it
i mean and the mood the tone the
photography just the kind it's funny we
had our very gritty nolan movies that
you know felt like they did something to
bring
batman and superheroes in general more
towards the ground level and this
feels like that's happening again but in
a in a way that feels entirely new and
fresh it's weird because
it does look darker and more grounded
again
at least as compared to like justice
league but uh this yeah it looks
just like a film it looks like a noir
batman
film and i love to the hints at it
sounds like riddler right
paul dano's like voice kind of messed up
or whatever
yeah you know and giving these clues
these hints about like you know where do
you turn your blind eye you know his
sense of justice the bad sense of
justice
so this is exactly what i would have
wanted from the first trailer it's very
much
batman and the cops and the mystery of
what is happening
right now doing the detect you got
everything here you got character-driven
bruce wayne batman storyline
where's the line there you get a little
bit of a voice of it sounded like alfred
becoming quite a celebrity he says i
think right you get jeff jeffrey right
looks
awesome as gordon it looks awesome
you're getting that element
it this whole thing feels like thematic
exploration you're getting great action
the batmobile in action looks sick
this looks you know what i can't handle
this i know i know it's overwhelming
it's overwhelming
and this one looks like it might have a
quiet sense of menace i guess that's
what's kind of different to me
between this and the nolan verse is like
this looks like it might have
quietly sinister moments yeah real like
evil lurking in the shadows of gotham
it's the whole thing with the duct tape
and the whole uh no more lies and yeah
face all
bandages it's so nasty i feel like so
down to the ground they're taking
inspiration from a lot of comics i get a
big sense of the hush comics in here as
well
i just want to watch this dc fandom you
guys killed it he has killed it
20 21 just skipped comic-con god
phantom they killed it yeah plus static
shock movie i don't care
this sure is not monetized because of
the
this nirvana song being in here this is
epic
this is amazing yeah oh you get the new
our mystery investigative thing as well
on top of it
guys how pumped are you as pumped for
this
are you insane are you having as much
trouble articulating as
we are now because uh
we we we got i love that they left the
uh the 20 and 21 a question mark as well
yeah it go it works for multiple
ways multiple layers you get the like
the riddler thing yeah
the mystery thing the covet thing you
got it all yeah we're getting
one 21-31 41.51
subscribe click the bell tell us your
thoughts
thank you god thank you dc fandom
patriot daysha
daniel gallagher our friend from
scotland there's
more to you than meets the eye all we
talk about are the pharmacy things and
how you're scottish
but you know what else his name actually
gives a lot of clues into who he is
d stands for delayed
because he constantly messages me way
way way
after i've messaged him already a stands
for
abundant with joy
n stands for
nexus you put in the blank as to why
you are the nexus i
stands for inimitable because
no one can imitate you wow what a
fancy word thanks it just came
just now e for electrician
because on top of being a pharmacist i
imagine he's got some good
electrician skills as well he's a man's
man and
uh the l stands for
lusty cause daniel wow
talk about a great big word
location cause he's a talkative guy
huh
i feel lusty when i think of daniel it's
i feel he's got boat because he's at the
pharmacy too if you're having trouble in
that department he can help you out you
can't talk your way out of this one